I could read this this filmography
forever Bowfinger Austin Powers Boogie
Nights a drugstore cowboy and then of
course we all know from swingers right
here on the Rich Eisen show currently
starring on every Tuesday night right
now Law & Order true Kron the Menendez
murders Heather Graham good to see you
Heather thanks for having me on your
show right back but before we before we
get into film and what you're doing on
the show I couldn't help but notice that
you and LeBron James crossed paths
recently on your you know on your
Instagram or on your social media the
king himself
exciting well I was having a birthday
dinner with my friend Molly Shannon
she's amazing and so we're having dinner
and we saw that LeBron James was sitting
at the table next to us and and and
Molly said we gotta get a picture with
him and I and I'm more shy so I said no
we can't bother him no no no no he's
like we're getting a picture she grabbed
my arm she pulls me over to and we're
and she just said you know her son is
such a huge fan she's like I can't leave
without you know showing my son that I
met LeBron James okay and he was so
sweet you know because it's kind of rude
he's sitting there with his wife and his
friends were at like some fancy
restaurant and he totally did it it was
so sweet yeah cuz dinner that usually
you know there's two there's two spots
you're not supposed to bother any yeah
Molly so charming so I kind of how could
you say no to Molly
everybody loves Molly like if I walk
down the street with Molly her fans were
like rabid right people get so excited
to meet her so I just thought Molly's
kind of got a free pass in that like
that's true I mean you know you too I
mean obviously and LeBron is you know
he's got it he's he's got comedy chops I
mean you just saw I mean he's so tall
you're just looking at this person like
how is this person so tall but like I
said there's two spots usually Heather
it's it's it's while they're eating yeah
and yeah that's rude yeah has anyone
ever come up to you like an either one
of those spots and say yeah I usually
would do it unless I don't know
sometimes it's rude to the people that
you're with you don't want to but if
there's a big group of people sometimes
it's intimidating like once I was taking
salsa classes in Mexico and these people
recognized me so I took a picture but
then everyone else in the whole place
recognized I was famous than everyone in
the whole place wanted to take a picture
salsa in Mexico
yeah I mean I ended up taking like 35
pictures how good are you now with the
salsa I'm okay I'm pretty good okay yeah
did you have play sports as a kid or did
you play sports like basketball I'm
pretty good at basketball cuz I kind of
was a gawky grew tall really fast so I
was tall so I was good at basketball
that was your game yeah and then I got
into karate for a while I did Taekwondo
karate yes okay I love Taekwondo it's
really cool then I recently went to
Korea I was working on this Food Show
and I realized I still remembered some
of my Taekwondo moves
so did you don't have to put it into
practice I mean no but when I was doing
the class regular I did feel really
tough I just said you know I just felt
like I was ready to kick someone's ass
you know Heather Graham here on the Rich
Eisen show I want to walk you through
some of the movies that you've done to
me
swingers is a it's a perfect movie that
is a perfect movie movies made for so
little money you would not even believe
it's amazing they made that movie for
$250,000 how did you get involved in
that I got involved because Jon Favreau
and I worked on this other thing that
was like this 30 minutes short that was
on Showtime so I met him on that he said
he was writing a movie and then he
offered me the part it was no it was it
was very it was no money and he said you
have to learn how to swing get so we
used to go to the derby every night and
he would teach me how to swing dance for
a month it was amazing because I learned
how to swing down so you got the salsa
in the swing dancing you got that done
but to me you know that movie again for
so many guys you know who wanted to be
the Vince Vaughn character but are
really in real life the Jon family
pretty great life I don't think we can
feel bad for the character in the movie
of course not to get to a regular guy
sensitive not to get all psychological
with you here and deep into my own cool
guy you don't to be the yeah but the guy
who calls up his ex-girlfriend 15 times
like that scene I watch it through my
fingers like it's a horror movie see
that too you know I think a girl can
relate to that to really just kind of
going insane when you like someone and
you're not your best self you know but
just defeat the the fact the fact though
that that you show up at the end and it
all works out for Jon Favreau you gave
us all
in the world and then he went on to
direct Iron Man and The Avengers
everything worked out and then obviously
Austin Powers you got involved in that
right in the middle of the height of it
I mean how would you able to get through
some of these scenes in this movie I
don't know I've been really lucky to
work with a lot of comedic genius people
you know and hopefully I think it's
taught me to have a better sense of
humor in life Steve Martin no I mean
that is really it was even more it was
so exciting just as a kid you know when
you watch someone as a kid it's
different when you're an adult and you
go well this person's a comedic genius
but I'm an adult right if you grow up
watching someone and then you meet them
it's a it's a crazy feeling yeah
excitement Hughes King Tut I know that
was I used to have a crush on him I'd be
like watching King Tut and I'm like he's
so cute and crush on him did you explain
that to Steve Lee I think I might have
yeah I think I did yeah I think he was
flattered it's flattering yeah he looks
the same yeah he's just he's cool he's
like a cool guy he looks the exact same
it is it is truly unbelievable yeah and
then I mean you have been in so many for
the lack of better phrase like guys guy
movies also it's funny cuz I think I'm
kind of a feminist but I always end up
with the real guy guys I dunno I do yeah
did you meet Tyson on the set was Mike
Tyson yes when you were there yeah
mm-hmm okay yeah and I mean he's been
here Wow I bet once yeah and then I
asked him a question about how how he's
different now than when he used to fight
and he basically started saying I don't
want to talk about that because I don't
want to go back to my fighting days and
he kind of gave me this look that's when
I threw the commercial break right on
the spot seems you hit a nerve I want to
know more I love psychology what is that
what is the craziest time you've ever
had on one of these movie sets of any of
these movies that you've been on one
that you you would like you remember it
was just that I mean I'm sure I could
think of a lot of different ones but I
guess just cuz you were talking about
The Hangover it's weird to play like a
stripper right and be at a strip club
and you're pretending to be a stripper
and I play kind of these sexual parts
but in my real life I'm pretty you know
sweet I'm not that crazy right so it's
very weird to be doing that so you don't
you don't roller skate
make it around and real-life solution it
seems more fun I can't see through these
roles if I was this really wild person
not to make it terribly awkward but
that's what the three of us do to
prepare for the show you guys all should
have done that yeah I actually really do
roller skate I want to see both of you
guys yes that would be cool if you guys
were all naked rollerskating around when
I came in I don't know not the first
word we're trying to figure all that out
but Boogie Nights to me is another that
to me that is a remote drop movie for me
no matter where I pick it up it is as
intense as possible what was it about
well what was it like around Burt
Reynolds on that set and everybody else
that you were around well I just felt so
lucky to work with Paul Thomas Anderson
and all those great actors and that was
just a job where you go Thank You
universe like this was a great fortune
to be in this movie I'm so glad I got to
be in it and yeah just you're looking at
all these people
Burt Reynolds and Julianne Moore and you
just it's exciting to me were heroes
yeah I mean at that time people didn't
know who he was as much he was just
starting but you just know that that guy
was brilliant he was just a poor guy was
an idiot behind the wheel of the car and
just telling me what an idiot gosh that
was that was incredible and now the loan
order true car to true crime the
Menendez murders you play the mistress
of the Menendez brothers psychiatrist
played my friend Josh Charles in this
and what was this experience like for
you and still going on we're still
shooting it I still we're still shooting
episode seven and eight but it's been
really you know right that's that's only
a month away so we actually sit down at
couch and see this thing yeah I guess
that's how they shoot TV oh yeah okay
but the case is really interesting I
remember as a kid you know knowing about
it and it just sounded so disturbing but
knowing all the details of the case it's
way more disturbing and it's just really
truth is stranger than fiction there's
so many strange details yeah and it that
was actually going on when you were
doing swingers 1989 six yeah yeah I was
a little bit off right there so you were
doing Drugstore Cowboy yeah
more than but actually I work with yeah
yeah I just suddenly went to the OJ
Simpson case thinking that I work with
OJ Simpson which is not what we were
talking about milk it's another huge
case that I work with him on a Disney
Sunday night movie of the week say what
what I worked with him on a Disney
Sunday night movie of the week before he
okay
what was the name of the Disney movie
it's called student exchange I mean I
didn't really know him I was like a
teenager in high school but I remember
meeting him and then later on thinking
when I met that guy
on a Disney movie yes like the football
coach of this high school go figure
yeah well it's been a pleasure meeting
you press that I didn't say that I
directed a movie what'd you do oh yeah
yeah that's coming out in February yes
okay and that's with Molly Shannon's in
that yeah Thomas Lennon who is his funny
is all good
he's amazing and Angela Kinsey who
everyone knows from the office yes
that's pretty cool yeah that's coming
out in February yeah what's that about
it's a sex comedy fantastic is there is
there any roller skating in this at all
I know roller skating no well it's great
to see you here again I'm a big fan come
back any time when you've come back when
you want to promote half magic you got
it thanks for sharing the roller skating
story Mike that was really great we got
Heather Graham right here check out Law
& Order true crime the Menendez murders
every Tuesday night on NBC
just as it aired last night 10:00 p.m.
Eastern Time nine percent 9 p.m. Central
Time the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show app
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show